[Música]
6 de febrero de 1952 muere el rey Jorge
vi de Reino Unido inmediatamente su hija
mayor sube el trono como Isabel II
2 de junio de 1953
tras más de un año de preparación y luto
por el difunto Rey su coronación sería
la primera en transmitirse íntegramente
por televisión rompiendo así miles de
años de secretismo además era también la
primera vez que se filmaba a color
la ceremonia empezó con una procesión
Que incluía varios jefes de estado y
miembros reales tanto británicos como
extranjeros partiendo del Palacio de
buckingham y atravesando las calles de
Londres hasta llegar a la abadía de
westmins
Isabel II llegó a la abadía a las 11 de
la mañana en el gol State coach el
carruaje de la familia real desde los
tiempos de Jorge IV en el siglo XVIII
llevaba un vestido en el que se habían
bordado los emblemas florales de los
países de la coma West y el manto de
estado la famosa capa de terciopelo y
arminio
el momento más importante de la
ceremonia comenzó Isabel se sentó en el
trono y los obispos se le entregaron los
objetos religiosos la Biblia una patenia
y un cáliz y los símbolos del poder real
la corona de San Eduardo las espadas y
centros ceremoniales y el orbe real el
arzobispo de canterbury le colocó la
corona y la bendijo sus familiares
cercanos incluido su esposo la
homenajearon
con la ceremonia terminada empezó la
procesión de regreso al palacio de
buckingham El recorrido pasaba por
algunos de los lugares más icónicos de
Londres en una ruta de 8 km y terminó
con una exhibición de la real fuerza
aérea
al llegar al palacio fiel a la tradición
la nueva reina salió al balcón y la
multitud enloqueció
entre sus acompañantes destacaba un
pequeño Carlos de 4 años el niño llamado
a cómo andar los destinos de la casa
real más importante del mundo
[Aplausos]